hi so I've been keeping commonplace
books throughout my PhD and I just
finished my previous one and I'm gonna
start writing in a new one quite soon
and I thought this would be the perfect
time to kind of teach you how I keep my
commonplace book and what I write in it
and how I found that it benefited me
throughout my PhD so a commonplace book
is a personalized collection of quotes
observations and knowledge gathered from
various sources over time it serves as a
reference memory aid and a tool for
reflection allowing individuals to
revisit and contemplate accumulated
wisdom and insights traditionally kept
in a notebook form its contacts are
organized thematically or according to
personal preference so people have kept
commonplace books throughout history one
of the first people that you may know
that has kept a commonplace book is
Marcus Aurelius so in his renowned work
meditations a Cornerstone of stoic
philosophy it originated as a personal
compilation of notes for Reflections and
quotes and if you haven't read
meditations I would definitely try to
read it because I personally really like
when you read it it kind of feels as if
it's quite a modern form of text because
stoic philosophy is still quite relevant
even in the current day and age but also
other people have kept commonplace books
so for example you have Leonardo da
Vinci Isaac Newton and Thomas Jefferson
they all kept some form of notebook that
helped them reflect on certain ideas and
help them in their creative Pursuits so
that's why I would argue that every one
of us should have a commonplace book to
help us get our thoughts and really
reflect on certain ideas that we have so
maybe you have seen online that a lot of
people keep their commonplace books or
their second brain as some people call
it on for example apps like notion or
Evernote however I also really like to
have a Common Place book in a paper
format and that's because I find it a
little bit more creative and a lot more
personal and that is because on a paper
format I find that you can for example
also use other forms of reflection such
as drawing so how to start your
commonplace book so first of all you
need to select the right medium so I
personally found throughout my years as
a PhD student and also a student before
that that I really like the bullet
Journal style and I think because a
bullet Journal is the most blank canvas
almost you can get without having a
totally blank space and I find that it
allows for a lot of like creative
thoughts and that you can really fill it
in however you like and personally I
always just buy a really cheap bullet
Journal so this one was from flying
tiger and I think it was something like
four Euros and it really serves its
purpose so I write different things in
my commonplace book I kind of use it as
a lab notebook for example so every time
I do any type of experiment I usually
write down what kind of ideas I'm having
throughout the experiment and also what
went wrong and this usually really works
if you're doing a lot of experiments
simultaneously to reflect back on what
and wrong During certain periods but
also what you tried so sometimes if
you're working on something for a year
you kind of forget the type of
Reflections you have throughout an
experiment and the type of things you
learned and I usually just note this
down as I'm programming as I'm going
through my day in the lab and I really
found that over the years these
notebooks become really golden in the
sense that the type of Reflections I had
throughout experiments you cannot really
find anywhere else online and they're
only in my personal notebook another
thing that I do is that I track
throughout the day the type of output I
have and especially for a PhD because
your goals are so fuzzy it's kind of
demotivating sometimes that you really
have a sense that you accomplish nothing
so something that I track is the amount
of pages I write throughout the day and
my goal is kind of like five pages and
by doing this I kind of see that on
average I'm between three and six pages
every day and I do see that I have some
type of output even on days that I I
feel really unproductive or that I only
made experiments that really failed so I
think having something that you can
track over multiple days that kind of
motivates you is for me really helpful
as well I also track what gives me
energy throughout the day this is a tip
I learned to kind of see which part of
your job you really like and something I
noticed is that for example I really
like teaching students and I really like
giving courses or doing administrative
work I really dread so that really
drains my energy so now I try to
throughout the day in periods that I'm a
little bit tired I try to plan things
out give me energy and I try to avoid
things that drain my energy and I think
by tracking this throughout the day I
got a better Insight in what actually it
is about a PhD that I really enjoy doing
so another few things that I do are like
I have certain markers and this is more
from the bullet Journal style so I use a
brain when I have a new idea or I hear
some idea that I think like I should
really work on this during my PhD I use
um exclamation mark for things that I
have to do quite soon and that are quite
important and then I use a heart for
personal thoughts so I also write in
this commonplace book personal thoughts
or feelings that I have and throughout
my life I've tried journaling in a
really set specific style but I noticed
that I always fell off the wagon whereas
like just writing it throughout my
science thoughts actually helps me
reflect a lot more on what I'm feeling
as well and that's because personally
for me science and emotions or these
kind of things aren't really separated
they're all just intertwined in my daily
life so just writing it down in my
common Facebook allows me to reflect on
certain feelings that I'm having as well
so in general I found that there are
certain benefits of having a commonplace
book one of the most obvious ones is
that it really helps me clear out my
scientific ideas so usually I also draw
my scientific ideas I reflect on my
scientific ideas and I really found
throughout the years that having a
commonplace book really helps you
clarify what you want to do in science
and also has helped you get over certain
hurdles because sometimes you feel
you're really stuck and then leaving
through my commonplace book I kind of
find different ideas or solutions to my
own problems because a lot of times I've
reflected beforehand on certain problems
that I could encounter throughout my
scientific career another way that I
found it really helpful is to combine
certain creative ideas so I also write
down if I find really nice quotes or if
I see a beautiful painting or something
like this and it really allows me to
make quite Creative Connections between
different fields which I don't really
think is possible unless you have a
commonplace book like this and the
biggest advantage that I found is that
it also allows you to have a
conversation with your past self so if
you've kept commonplace books or
notebooks throughout a long period of
time and I revisit them once I've
finished one and then I also usually
revisit older ones so that's about once
every six months I go through my old
commonplace books and it really feels
like having a conversation with your
past self because you see in which areas
you have grown but you also see which
parts of you are consistent throughout
your life so something that I've been
working on consistently throughout my
PhD is really this work-life balance and
whenever I revisit old notebooks I
always see that I'm continuously working
on this and that this always stays a
struggle like there are periods of
stress where I get really sucked into
science and do almost nothing else and
always when I read my hard thoughts
during those days it's always like I
should rest more I should have a better
work-life balance and these kind of
things and it is really reflective to
see that this thought never really goes
away and I think as a student and as a
PhD student this is just a struggle that
is part of the job so this was just a
really short video on how I get a common
Facebook and I would love to hear if you
are keeping a commonplace book how you
do it what kind of thoughts you write in
it what kind of things you collect in it
or if you're doing it online what kind
of benefits you find from having it
online and if you're interested in
productivity or these kind of things I
would definitely try this video next and
otherwise see you next week bye